[Music]
my name is Patti Whitehead I grew up
outside of Athens Georgia and I'm an
attorney in Nashville
I grew up in a pretty middle-class
family never wanted for anything so when
I got into high school and wanted to do
things that cost a little bit more money
I just always ask my dad hey daddy
I need a 20 I want to go to dinner and
he was only well money doesn't grow on
trees but here you go but then when I
got my first job when I was a sophomore
at college I didn't really have any
bills I didn't have a car so I just
spent a lot of money on clothes and
shopping I never really thought about it
until I needed to house my apartment I
said I don't have enough money to get a
bed or computer - we'll open up a credit
card four months later when finals time
came around and you were down to almost
zero in your bank account you didn't
really think about it at all but you
still went out because you could and you
just put it on the credit card because
oh finals are over we need to go
celebrate
and then when graduation got closer and
I've been job searching for a year and
it still wasn't there and bar exam fees
were coming up sort of thinking wow this
is going to be it's going to be an issue
I went and talked to my landlord said
hey for the next few months things are
going to be pretty tight I'm going to
try to pay when I can you know I'm
always going to keep you advised but I
don't know how it's going to work out
this time all my credit cards were maxed
out and they had closed them but it got
to the point where I couldn't feed
myself at all I couldn't go out all I
did was work study for the bar exam I
got on government assistance so I didn't
pay any of my credit cards for that
entire summer at all because I couldn't
I talked to them every month but I'm in
the collection called started and I
would just put my phone on airplane mode
all the time so I wouldn't hear them and
I was working for jobs still looking for
a full-time job that I went to my friend
that something needs to change here it
was a real turning point for me because
I would just stay up at night crying I
had no idea what to do I was like
they're going to evict me soon and my
friend of like you should go to
financial teeth University I'm Dorothy
bridges and I'm an FPU coordinator petty
and the first night of our class she
came in and she set right up front in
the corner and I'll never forget because
we finished the class and the way
everywhere everyone had left adding a
still setting there and she was crying
she was in tears and saying that there
was no way she could do this and get out
of this because she was in such a mess
it really made me confront exactly what
was going on in my life mine hit rock
bottom it would be five thousand dollars
even get called up and I don't have five
thousand dollars how my folks save a
thousand dollars I I don't think I
really told anybody how bad it was until
I was at the club and so I asked her I
said just give us nine weeks give us
nine weeks and we're going to work with
you and we're going to walk with you and
so I asked her to go home that night and
I said I want you to sit down and right
where you are right now and how you're
feeling and I said them in nine weeks
from now when we finished let's see
where you are
let's compare because I said I think
you're going to find yourself in a much
different place I didn't miss one class
I was like I have to go to this every
single week because I knew I was just
been so much trouble I'm like I got it
just give this at all that I have at the
moment and the more I did the more I
followed the program the more things
just started happening in my life that
really worked out in the time of the
class I paid off nine thousand dollars
in nine weeks
which was really exciting if anyone and
told me I would do that I would both
laugh and said you are crazy
I haven't even made $9,000 those years
but I did so at the end of the nine we
always ask for class members to share
with us and what they've learned and
what they've gained through the class
and who she was in tears but it was much
different this time it was that first
Mikey who tears of joy relief of hope
that she you know she finally had some
hope and that she saw that she could do
it and she had the tools to do it so I
guess it's been about three or four
months since I took the class and I
haven't paid off all my credit cards yet
but I'm very very close to getting my
consumer debt done with my
projectionists to pay off around thirty
five thousand dollars and a little over
a year which is exciting with student
loans I have approximately one hundred
and fifty thousand dollars a semi nice
house or condo here in Nashville and
when I've looked at it if I were to stay
in my same salary level I'll have all my
student loans paid off in five years
[Music]